bonjour jean eric branaa remercier de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france
vous connaissez donald trump vous avez
écrit des ouvrages le concernant et le
qualifie ces manifestations je cite de
honte il menace de déployer l'armée
provocation vis-à-vis de la population à
frohmuhl afro-américaine ou main tendue
vers son électorat en vue du 3 novembre
date de l'élection présidentielle
américaine
bonjour galerie en fait il ya même une
troisième voie c'est une échappatoire
pour donald trump qui essaie alors que
sa campagne est un peu moribonde et on
le comprend avec cette crise sanitaire
qui a quand même renversé tous les
chiffres les plus optimistes qui nous
annonçaient depuis le départ et bien ils
essaient aujourd'hui de relancer la
campagne en appuyant sur la loi l'ordre
la bible et les armes la religion et les
arbres et haies en réalité il est mort
et à partir de là arriver à élargir
cette base pas spécialement galvaniser
sa base qui est déjà galvanisé qui ne
l'a jamais quittée et qui le soutient
après quoi qu'il fasse depuis le départ
mais pour l'élargir il se dit que en
désignant les voyous qui sont dans la
rue ce sont ses propres termes ce ne
sont pas les miens il espère que les
bonnes gens pensent les gens qui sont
chez eux et qui forment la majorité
silencieuse vont voter pour lui en
espérant qu'il va résoudre la situation
seulement on l'a vu et on l'a vu sur vos
images c'est pas c'est pas des voyous
qui sont dans la rue c'est c'est
monsieur madame tout le monde c'est pour
ça que les policiers se sont agenouillés
pour soutenir cette amérique quelles
aides dont ils font partie tout comme
les manifestants et donc donald trump se
trouve aujourd'hui à contre-courant par
rapport à ce qui se passe dans la
société très mauvaise analyse de sa part
très mauvaise campagne qu'elle est en
train de lancer et ellis mais aux graves
en danger pour nos vents et comment
l'opinion publique américaine
vittel ces événements de l'intérieur est
ce qu'il ya des sondages par exemple nom
n'a pas encore de sondage c'est encore
un petit peu on était quand même sur le
feu de l'action c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
de sens jourdan sondages en tant que tel
mais on a un sondage dans la rue puisque
on a vu comment tout cela s'est
disséminé sur les états unis d'abord
centrée sur le nord
centre des états unis minneapolis le
minnesota et puis rapidement ça à gagner
sur quelques grandes villes aujourd'hui
plus de 250 grandes villes aux états
unis sur l'ensemble du territoire
ça c'est un sondage en réel
en voyant ce sont très souvent des
manifestations très pacifique
on le voit dans vos images pendant la
journée la nuit c'est une autre histoire
mais la nuit les gouverneurs ont fait on
fait appel à l'état d'urgence et à la
garde nationale pour essayer de calmer
la situation
vous ai posé une question sur l'opinion
publique une question également sur la
presse comment est-ce qu'elle couvre ces
manifestations on a vu certains médias
comme cnn pour pas le citer ils ont
diffusé des images de leurs journalistes
arrêtés par la police
oui ça a étonné c'est vrai que des
départs on a parlé de violences
policières et c'était vraiment ce qui
était mis en avant alors ces
arrestations de journalistes ou même de
blessure on a vu aussi des images d'un
des photographes de presse qui a été
frappé par un policier assez durement et
visiblement sans raison ont étonné on se
demande vraiment ce qui se passait tout
ça est vraiment inutile mais beaucoup
beaucoup de réaction de syndicats de
policiers de policiers et de
responsables de la police et de
responsables politiques pour demander à
ce que bien sûr tout cela ne soit pas
pris en compte et où s'arrête et pour le
condamner donc on va dire ce sont des
actes isolés certainement vous parliez
de l'arrestation du journaliste yann l
le gouverneur du minnesota s'était
excusé quelques minutes après en faisant
relâche et bien évidemment le
journaliste et quelle issue possible au
final ça dure depuis une semaine on a
l'impression qu'il va y avoir de
nouvelles nuits de violences certains
parlent de convergence des luttes après
les inégalités sociales déjà causé un
parent par la pandémie
alors tout est possible il peut y avoir
effectivement mais communal et trump il
envoie l'armée
ils essaient de réprimer on pense à bien
sûr aux manifestations de détroit en
c'était une seule peine avait justement
l'on voit de l'armée ça peut durer un
petit peu plus toujours en 67 ya qu'on
l'a mis en était brûlot sur l'ensemble
des états unis avec 86 morts à la fin et
la personne de
que ça aille dans cette direction ou
l'année 68 qui a été également horrible
au niveau des morts et des blessés et du
nombre de manifestations et de leur
importance plus plus sincèrement on
pense quand même que il va y avoir un
projet qui va être sorti rapidement par
les candidats ou par une autre et là
bien sûr je pense plus à dubaï donne
puisqu'il est déjà donc cette mouvance
et dans cette direction alors que donald
trump a plutôt pris la voie de la loi et
l'ordre comme on le disait tout à
l'heure et c'est ce qu'attend de ses
militants ces manifestants ils attendent
surtout que les quatre prisonniers les
quatre policiers sur les faits
prisonniers qu'ils soient traînés devant
la justice parce que l'injustice
elle est là elle est savoir que ses
hommes ont pu tuer jazz floride et être
simplement renvoyés de leur poste sans
qu'il y ait des poursuites judiciaires
c'est ce qui est demandé le temps que se
sera pas fait ça s'arrêtera pas mais une
fois que ce sera fait on peut espère
effectivement que les émeutes s'arrête
rapidement derrière question aux joueurs
avec branagh manifestation à hong kong
chez les jeunes en france marche pour le
climat climat à travers le monde
désormais les états unis qui vivent des
manifestations de masse est ce qu'on
peut y voir un parallèle
ou pas moi je n'y vois aucun parallèle
je ne comprends même pas le lien qui est
fait on peut toujours tirer des liens on
disait il ya des gens dans la rue où il
ya un malaise il ya des inégalités mais
tout ça n'a aucun sens là on est dans un
contexte très américain c'est un nouveau
chapitre qui s'est rajouté aidant dans
un roman national qui est commencée il
ya très longtemps
vous savez le problème entre noirs et
blancs a été quand même pointé depuis le
début de cette république le rapport
4,967 expliqué qu' il y allait avoir le
développement d'une deux sociétés
parallèles entre les afro-américains et
des blancs on en est là aujourd'hui
parce que les inégalités sont flagrantes
entre les deux est ce que demande cette
communauté comme l'ensemble des
communautés c'est que tout le monde soit
considérée au même niveau c'est pas du
tout la même chose que les gilet jaune
ou que ce qui se passe encore vraiment
les comparer me sembles moi totalement
hallucinant merci beaucoup jean eric
branaa d'avoir répondu à une question je
rappelle que vous êtes maître de
conférences à paris deux spécialistes de
la politique et de la société américaine
auteur de nombreux ouvrages sur les
états unis